en este vídeo aprenderá a manejar y
tratar el nivel bajo de azúcar en la
sangre
vea el vídeo completo antes de realizar
el tratamiento para el nivel bajo de
azúcar en la sangre
si se trata de una emergencia comienza
el tratamiento para el nivel bajo de
azúcar en la sangre a medida que el
vídeo le muestra qué hacer después de
ingerir alimentos que contengan
carbohidratos su cuerpo los descompone
en un azúcar denominado glucosa las
células del cuerpo usan este azúcar para
producir la energía necesaria para
funcionar adecuadamente
el nivel bajo de azúcar en la sangre
denominado hipoglucemia ocurre cuando la
glucosa o azúcar en la sangre disminuye
por debajo de los niveles normales o por
debajo del intervalo ideal establecido
por su médico
la hipoglucemia puede deberse a tomar
demasiada insulina o tomar demasiados
medicamentos que eleve los niveles de
insulina
no consumir suficientes alimentos o
esperar demasiado entre comidas
ejercitarse demasiado
o beber alcohol en exceso
la reacción de cada persona ante un
nivel bajo de azúcar en la sangre es
diferente debe conocer sus propios
signos y síntomas
los síntomas comunes de hipoglucemia un
nivel bajo de azúcar en la sangre
incluyen temblores o mareos
mal humor o nerviosismo
sudoración
hambre
dolor de cabeza ansiedad
confusión
visión borrosa y debilidad
si la hipoglucemia no se trata a su
nivel de azúcar en la sangre podría
disminuir hasta un nivel peligrosamente
bajo que requeriría de atención de
emergencia inmediata manejar y tratar la
hipoglucemia implica revisar su nivel de
azúcar en la sangre y volver a alcanzar
el intervalo ideal mediante algún tipo
de alimento con alto contenido de azúcar
o un medicamento
necesitará lo siguiente un medidor de
glucosa en sangre junto con los
materiales asociados y una fuente de
alimento de acción rápida que contenga
entre 15 y 20 gramos de azúcar o
carbohidratos como 3 o 4 tabletas de
glucosa
si no tiene tabletas de glucosa puedes
sustituirlas con alguna de estas fuentes
de alimentos 4 onzas de jugo
una taza de leche
4 onzas de gaseosa común
una cucharada de azúcar
o cinco dulces pequeños
paso 1 revise su nivel de azúcar en la
sangre con un medidor de glucosa
paso 2 si su nivel de azúcar en la
sangre es inferior a 70 o inferior a su
nivel ideal como beba una fuente de
acción rápida de azúcar o carbohidratos
paso 3 espere 15 minutos luego revise su
nivel de azúcar en la sangre nuevamente
paso 4 si es un nivel de azúcar en la
sangre es muy bajo repite el paso 2 y el
paso 3
luego revise su nivel de azúcar en la
sangre nuevamente
paso 5 después de que su nivel de azúcar
en la sangre regrese al nivel ideal si
debe esperar 30 minutos o más antes de
ingerir la próxima comida como un
refrigerio que contenga proteínas y
carbohidratos como galletas saladas y
mantequilla de maní o medio sándwich de
jamón o pavo
de otro modo asegúrese de seguir sus
hábitos de alimentación normales o plan
de alimentación
se ha tratado su nivel de azúcar en la
sangre dos veces y este permanece por
debajo de 70 llame a su proveedor de
atención médica de inmediato
puede prevenir la hipoglucemia de la
siguiente manera revisa con regularidad
su nivel de azúcar en la sangre siga su
plan de alimentación normal no salte
ninguna comida
mantenga una fuente de azúcar de acción
rápida con usted todo el tiempo toma el
medicamento para la diabetes según las
indicaciones del médico realice
actividad física con regularidad y lleva
consigo un juego de emergencia de
glucagón que no esté vencido si se los
recetaron